now to give you a sense of how serious
the democrats are about this crush going
on at our southern border
listen to the first question that was
posed by the ranking member at today's
homeland security hearing
the homeland threat pitcher has shifted
dramatically from foreign terrorists to
domestic terrorists and particularly
racially motivated violent extremists
who present the most lethal threat to
the homeland
what is your current assessment of the
domestic terrorism threat to our country
mr chairman it is our assessment that
domestic violent extremism poses the
greatest terrorism-related threat
to our homeland okay
translation you should be far more
afraid of your fellow americans than the
millions of illegal aliens being bust
and flown all over the country in the
middle of the night got it
of course we all know that under biden
dhs secretary alejandro mayorkas he's
not really in charge of the southern
border
as a practical matter the mexican drug
syndicates are
millions of illegals have already
crossed our border since biden came into
office in just the month of march march
that we just had
customs and border protection say they
encountered more than 20
221
000 illegals now to give you a sense of
how staggering this number is
when trump declared the border situation
an emergency which was three years ago
the number of monthly
apprehensions then
had hit 76 000
now because most migrants are gaming our
asylum laws one of the few tools that
border patrol agents had under biden was
title 42 which was the trump rule that
allowed for immediate turnaround of
migrants at the border due to these
covet concerns
and to understand how significant this
tool is
in march 109
549 encounters 50 of the total
were processed for expulsion under title
42 21 of all family unit individuals
were processed for expulsion under title
42 as well you understand that 220 000
about half immediately turn back not
bust around the country country because
of title 42 biden wants to get rid of
that
and of course because his team believes
borders are immortal immoral they are in
full support of dropping title 42
but because they know just how
detrimental this will be to all
americans they're passing the buck
title 42 is a public health authority
that rests
in the exclusive jurisdiction of the
centers for disease control and
prevention and they decide whether the
title 42 authority remains necessary
this is a reminder it is a health
authority not an immigration plan or an
immigration authority and the
determination about where we stand and
to lift it was made by the cdc
oh wait a second didn't they say this
was a whole of government approach at
the border don't you love that phrase
so without title 42 the number of
illegals flooding in will dwarf the
population of many american cities even
states in some cases by the end of
biden's first term
and of course that's the whole goal
and now americans are growing fed up new
polling is showing that they rate the
border issue second only to inflation as
their major concern now this makes total
sense
real wages are stagnating not keeping
with inflation so many other problems
are exacerbated by the open border
crime local budgets are being pressed
the drug epidemic
now understand this
more than a hundred and six thousand
americans died from overdoses from
november 2020 to november 2021.
simply put by refusing to do all that is
necessary at the border biden is
allowing china
through mexico to kill us with fentanyl
they say devon and a friend bought what
they thought was percocet from a drug
dealer on snapchat it's like a hole in
your heart and
there's really no way to fill that void
the norings say the pill devin took
turned out to be a hundred percent
fentanyl
trump of course predicted all this chaos
would happen
so in the end you're either a president
who believes in borders or you're not
and you're either a party that believes
in our sovereignty or national
sovereignty or not
but from bush to biden
they follow the same playbook it is
neither wise
nor realistic to round up millions of
people
many with deep roots in the united
states and send them across the border
and this was repeated today by biden's
dhs secretary
we inherited a broken and dismantled
system that is already under strain it
is not built to manage the current
levels and types of migratory flows only
congress can fix this
so after none of them were serious about
enforcing existing laws on enforcement
and removal and after none of them
pushed to tighten up the asylum rules
and in biden's case dropping title 42
of course migrants are going to rush the
border
our agents lives are endangered and one
texas national guardsmen died last week
trying to rescue a migrant in the rio
grande
these are the results of joe biden's
open borders agenda
but this is a pattern over three
administrations
and when the public outcry builds as
it's building now
they pivot to the comprehensive con
we need to resolve the status of the
illegal immigrants who are already in
our country
so that you can pass and i can sign
comprehensive immigration reform into
law
it is long past time to reform
an immigration system that right now
doesn't serve america as well as it
should the immigration reform is
supported by everyone from labor unions
to religious leaders to the u.s chamber
of commerce
let's get it done once and for all but
remember remember it's not amnesty no
they're going to be many hoops that
illegal immigrants will have to jump
through we promise
i believe that illegal immigrants who
have roots in our country and want to
stay
should have to pay a meaningful penalty
for breaking the law
to pay their taxes
to learn english if you've been in
america for more than five years
if you have children who are american
citizens or legal residents
if you register pass a criminal
background check this is an amnesty
they're required to take 11 years worth
they pay a fine they've got to learn to
speak english
then all you law and order people you're
subjected to an immigration sob story
you must remember that the vast majority
of illegal immigrants are decent people
who work hard
support their families
practice their faith these people
our neighbors
our classmates
our friends my immigration policy is
built around keeping families together
my favorite biden on immigration though
was from i guess it was eight years ago
it was during another immigration battle
where he admitted what we all know
they don't really think american
citizenship is all that special
you know
11 million people living in the shadows
i believe they're already
american citizens
yes he said that and comprehensive
immigration reform is just shorthand of
course for giving amnesty to i don't
know probably at this point
22 million illegals
and i love how they always say 11
million as if that number is frozen in
time
so it's hard to lose you lose count here
but i think it's at least the third or
fourth time in the past 15 years where
there are supposedly conversations about
comprehensive immigration reform
and it always happens when the border
becomes a political liability for
whatever globalist party is in charge i
remember in 2006 and 2007 bush tried to
do something with mccain and the
democrats but the grassroots rose up
including yours truly in talk radio and
it was defeated
in 2013 there was a gang of eight bill
and at one point marco rubio was leading
it he was operating in good faith i
think he was new to the senate he
smartly stepped away from it well that
went down in flames as well
and now i guess they're trying to do it
all over again
but smart conservatives know that the
promise of enforcement never comes
smart conservatives know that
they start talking about technology when
they do that well they're going to
install the stuff at the border drones
they're not serious at all
they'll get better video maybe of
thousands of people crossing that's
about it
the fact is we have a lot of politicians
in office who think that enforcing the
border is a moral crime
they think border enforcement is for
fascists only
plus they want to satisfy the chamber of
commerce which always wants an endless
stream of low-wage workers
the only way we can have a deal is if a
serious enforcement president is in
charge and of course when we had that
and president trump finally got better
control of the border with new policies
the democrats didn't want to do a deal
that tells you everything you need to
know
and when a republican is in office again
we will enforce the border
the trump remain and mexico policy
worked
title 42 worked
number of undocumented migrants being
stumped at the southern border has
dropped dramatically dipping 28 percent
from may to june homeland security says
about 104 000 people were apprehended in
june the first decline in months they
credit the agreement with mexico to
crack down on asylum seekers from
central america
that was because of a deal between the
trump administration and mexico now
going forward we should just assume that
when democrats are in charge we're going
to have open borders
agreeing to any deal with them in charge
would be like agreeing to i don't know a
political extortion scheme
and in the end would be worse not better
off
so put the pressure on if senators
tester in montana cortes masto and
nevada kelly in arizona hassan and new
hampshire new hampshire says oh we
support comprehensive immigration reform
just vote them out
don't fall for the con
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else